all right you guys know I am NOT one for
conspiracy theories but if you can't
hear me right now I'm going to punch
somebody we've tried this live stream a
couple of times and the audio is not
working I'm not a different computer
right now so this is God or if this
doesn't work then I will officially
think that YouTube has it in for me
because all right it sounds like it's
working you people are saying it's
working we're getting a thumbs up over
here all right so I mean Jesus Christ
I'm talking about how YouTube has told
us they tell they're telling us that
there's a bug with our channel so people
are being unsubscribe and you guys are
telling you to reading up subscribe we
have a whole other people that are
telling us they're not getting our
videos on there e and then twice I try
to do a live hangout on my computer the
same way we've always done it and the
audio did work twice I'm on a different
computer now so not exactly sure just
what happened there but alright well
we'll just chalk it up to non conspiracy
but anyway make sure you're subscribed
make sure you click that little bell
button so you get all of our
notifications now I started telling you
all the things that i want to tell you i
get you caught up with everything man
nothing is easy let's let's tweet out
that this you linker right okay so cool
hi everybody that was insane I just did
mine I basically you all just watch me
do mine for eight minutes what am I told
you my deepest darkest secrets who knows
alright so if you didn't see the video
this morning that would post it on
YouTube I'm very excited we got a lot of
good news and we are expanding the
Reuben report a few things fell into
place over the last couple weeks and we
were able to find a place and we will be
building a home studio we got we got an
awesome garage nice high ceilings that
we're going to be able to build a
full-on studio to unlimitedly be able to
do whatever we want whatever our
situation since we've gone independent
in June it's been great but the studio
that we're at you know they have other
things that are shooting there we can't
just be there all the time doing
whatever we log we have time limits and
and there are cost reasons that we just
can't shoot all the time but now we are
going to build our own studio so I took
out a massive
and you know I finally got ahead in life
let's try it again so I'm very excited
we are going to so starting next week we
are going to double the amount of shows
that we're doing will be doing two
interviews per week and we're gonna do
that as long as we can but the key to
this is we gotta hit this 30,000 thing
on patreon we looked at the budget and
we've to build out the studio so it's
just basically a garage we got a
soundproof it and light it and get
electric in there all kinds a lot of
stuff that we have to build out and you
guys have been great to us as you know
we are fan funded on patreon so you go
to patreon.com/scishow report or Ruben
report com / donate then you can donate
whatever you can a dollar two dollars
couples people do hundreds of dollars
whatever it is and depending on what you
do on patreon you hit different wards
anyway i'm going to give everybody shout
outs anyone that donates while i am live
right now on the YouTube you will get a
shout out right now live we just did one
of these on facebook and hope people
jumped in um and by the way if you
donate while I am live right now if you
donate fifty dollars or more on patreon
I will personally thank you on skype
today you just send us your skype me
about thank you on today that's 50 on
pager or if you donate a hundred on
paypal I will thank you on this on skype
after this personally you and me
one-on-one um and we're doing this all
week by the way so tomorrow so today
it's just the initial I'm gonna answer
all your questions we can talk about the
election all that kind stuff tomorrow
we're going to be doing a happy hour
situation we might do this patron for
patreon thing that we did last night
which got me wasted because I had to
take shots every two hundred fifty
dollars i ended up doing like six seven
shots of three hours nuts but people do
have a happy hour thing then on
Wednesday is the debate so we'll live
stream before and after that and then
Thursday and Friday we got a couple
other tricks up our sleeve so it is
patreon.com/scishow burn record of Ruben
report com so I show a name by the way
for those of you that are that are you
know part of this what's really cool is
that you know we got a lot email from
from young people and you know for
people that don't have a ton of money or
whatever it is so for those of you that
do know donate not only you donating to
help us build the show but you're
allowing the show not to go behind a
paywall which is I guess ultimate
what we would have to do and you're
letting other people get it for free so
that's that's actually very cool so
shout-out to Tyler who just donated on
paypal and Shawn who just donated on
patreon thank you guys alright cool so
if you want to jump in the comment
section um you can ask questions my guys
are going to shout some questions out of
me we can talk politics we can talk
election will you talk like we can talk
about the expanding the expansion of the
business you know I didn't realize
really when we did this thing back in
June that you know I was getting to
running I want to do what I'm doing on
the show the stuff that you see me doing
that's the stuff I care about now we got
a production company and it's an you
know there's accountants involved with
lawyers and health insurance Obama Kevin
oh all kinds of other [ __ ] but it's very
cool we're building something cool and I
think those of you that watch and
understand what I'm trying to do which
is talk to people from all sides yes I
focus more I focused more on trying to
clean up the left cuz i consider those
my people and i've been really
disappointed and watching what's
happened to liberalism over the past
year or so because it has regressed
liberals that should stand for free
speech and liberty and be about the
individual really a progressed into this
collective mindset of the oppression
Olympics of this whole thing a lot of
people will criticize me they'll say
well now you guys started image on and
you bet my lowing at Paul Joseph Watson
and their brightly maniacs are all
writers or other buzzwords and it's like
that means you're in it with none of my
guys know that means I talked to them
and I do have friends in my own life fed
up bleeps and I've also had plenty of
progressives like on Fugelsang and a
Reaper martin and michael ian black and
jimmy dore other people on and i've had
sam Harris who was talking about why
Trump would be a disaster in the very
next week I had dinesh d'souza who is
talking about why Hillary would be a
disaster so I'm really trying to bring
on a wide range of of people and I try
not to be too judgy I think that I you
know what I try to do sometimes people
scale a day we should be more combative
what I try to do is I let my guests
speak because I'm a firm believer that
if you let someone really expand on
their thoughts that eventually if their
thoughts your shitty they started like
giving them a rope and eventually they
start just tying your
on their neck and hanging themselves so
what would be the purpose of doing a
show where I just fight with people
every week yellow people but that's it
one of the things that we're going to do
so we're expanding to two interviews a
week we're going to do way more live
streaming so first off I'm working this
bar kitty time one or Wi-Fi so in the
new place we already ordered it we're
getting fiber optic cables so this we're
going to make this thing
state-of-the-art it's going to be really
cool so we'll have live streaming
capabilities and we're going to try to
do more with that I'd love to eventually
start doing some like weekly news
wrap-up I told you guys I don't want to
do the daily this thing I think it
becomes minutiae and you start chasing
stories just for clicks I don't want to
do that but we can just do so much more
if I get into Twitter find me somebody I
can say you know what how about I'll
jump into my studio Oh down the hall and
we can hash it out right now so there's
so many cool things we can do we can do
three our interviews if we want we can
really expand this I mean this this is
the final step I didn't think it was
going to happen so quickly but this is
truly the final step to us for coming
fully independent beholdin to know
network executive or anyone yelling in
my ear we will be beholding to you guys
the audience and the real beauty of that
you guys are as politically diverse as I
would want you to be so I it's not like
I have all people that are all Trump
people giving us money on patreon royal
Hilary people you guys are all over the
place too so that allows me to do what I
think is right and this gift that you
could possibly give me if you think if
you think of this as if that's what you
do let's do some quick shoulders right
now due to a couple shout outs and then
you guys can ask me questions election
what everyone do you ask these personal
stuff whatever works I want to thank
Jake on patreon I wanted to thank
another Jake on patreon I think we had a
facebook two three Jakes I want to thank
at TN i hope i pronounced your name
right on patreon who gave fifty dollars
and i want to thank mark on patreon and
utah and details and description she
taught so anyone as i said that anyone
that does 50 or more on patreon or 100
tomorrow hey pal i'm going to thank you
personally on skype after this the
details are right below that yarn you
can you can check that out alright again
I Thrones much time let me throw some
question
that me look what do you got her cheek
on YouTube he says I Dave I'm proud and
then ground floor when was the breaking
point community father Ruben port was
something needed all right so the
question was from George and thank you
for the next words Georgian basically
you sayin when was the breaking point
for when I thought this whole thing was
was needed you know when we've talked
about this with a few guests that I've
had but there were a couple moments
where my own political awakening because
as you guys know i was i was on tyt i
guess i consider myself a progressive
but i always wanted myself as a liberal
i was in that progressive world that
time there were a few moments obviously
the the sam Harris Ben Affleck moment on
real time and the gross and racist thing
and how the next day suddenly the onus
was on bill maher who had been the
standard-bearer left because after i
called him and sam Harris raises the
owners was something i'm bill r coupe
that he wasn't racist even though he had
been for every liberal cross everywhere
and i saw the way the left was throwing
bill maher and sam Harris especially Tim
obviously under the bus and all Sam did
was quote some pupils so that was the
beginning of it thing was huge also for
me that's when I saw the left again they
were upset that people drew cartoons and
they seem to be more outraged about that
and the actual dead people than the
actual people the cartoonists the
satirist who were murdered and then a
series of other things how he just
seemed like the left was judging
everybody everybody that they didn't
agree with everyone that the
progressives didn't agree with was a
homophobe and it is Lama pole bana
brings to this isn't a big know whatever
and I just thought it's just sloppy
thinking and what I try not to do even
though fight I criticize obviously
people on both sides but I try not to
demonize everyone's intentions and
that's why look I've even used the
phrase regressive left or talked about
less progressive left I'm talking about
their aggressive a little bit less
lately because I want people to realize
I cuz people are waking up and I don't
want them to think that that ultimately
were enemies because i want the left to
be better that's why i have focused on
the left you know think about it if i
was just another guy screaming about the
right all day long there's a kajillion
people doing it no one's adding anything
but i think
what I can add is that I want the left
to be more liberal a lot liberalism to
be more liberal I want us to use logic
and reason classical liberal principles
I want us to have a certain set of
beliefs about liberty and about the
individual that allow us to grow a
society properly at we can let's talk
about the role of government what taxes
should be for and why we shouldn't
nation build but we should have a strong
defense a movie I'm what I'm happy to to
you know share any of my political
thoughts with you guys for whatever
that's worth um so so that was the
breaking ball a few of those things at
once but yet the final snap was about a
year and a half I just couldn't take it
anymore i saw something so rotten in the
left as Ben Shapiro says and Ben is
obviously a conservative but he says the
left loves feelings over facts and
that's starting to become obvious to me
you can't just judge everything by your
gut emotion you have to judge it on
facts and that's what I would try to
bring to what I tried to do with this
show I hope I'm doing pretty decent job
of it all right you guys are jumping all
over patreon which is awesome so I want
to thank Derek who just donated on
paypal Sam on patreon a lot and on
patreon Joseph on patreon Eric on
patreon baba patriotic guardo up a tree
on thank you guys thank you guys you're
giving us the budget we're gonna build
this studio out as i said we hit 30,000
on patreon we can wire this thing we can
light this thing we can insulate it etc
etc and who knows what we can do i can
live stream everyday live streaming on
my ikea couch with rakia table the IBM
aqui a blanket um but will be in studio
will be able to do whatever we want as
if you longer interviews more new stuff
all kinds of cool stuff where we got uh
what is your guestlist dream guess my
dream guest wish so there's a lot of
people I would love to have bill maher
for several reasons I have more
disagreement to actually with bill now
than probably at any time book in the
past um because I do sense that he goes
a little too much to this all the Trump
people are racist I'm trying not to do
that are there some racist yes are there
some racists on the left yes um but I
try not to do that I think you guys know
that but I would love to talk to Bill
about the athletic thing but about his
political evolution
stand up I've met him a couple times
I've met with the producers over there
we're trying to get on get me on that
show so hopefully it'll happen look
sorry love to have him i would love to
have thomas soul we we've gone back and
forth with his people you know he's 86
years old he's up and stanford doesn't
sound like he does that many interviews
these days but we're doing the back and
forth and hopefully it'll happen I would
love to have Larry David I'd love to
have Jerry Seinfeld I'm gonna want I you
know I love talking to comics obviously
of course i would love to that me this
goes without saying i would love to have
Tom that I would love to have gluten
I'll tell you what I would do with both
Trump and Clinton to show you that I
would be fair and I would be honest and
just is I would interview them both the
exact same way I would answer asking the
exact same 10 questions and I wouldn't
we would not edit for content you know
Hillary's been doing all these things
where you know she goes on Eleanor she
goes on to ferns or she went on Steve
Harvey and they pre-planned the question
so all this stuff it's like these aren't
even remotely close to injuries now you
guys know my style I would not be the
most combative but I think you could ask
them certain questions in a way that you
would get a lot more out of them Jim
than just this prepackaged nonsense so
of course I would love to have them um I
would love to I would love to have
somebody like Jake Tapper on CNN who you
guys know my feelings about mainstream
media and CNN it's pretty terrible but I
think Jake's doing a decent enough job
he's trying you know it's very easy for
all of us that are that are in the
online media it's very easy for all of
us to [ __ ] all over everybody all day
you know turn on CNN be like a [ __ ]
idiot this month but there are some good
people there of course you know my
friend Don Lemon who had on the show is
on there I think he's trying to have on
his civil conversation of course each
channel as a couple people that I
figured he's in even though O'Reilly
I'll watch every now and again like
disagree with on so much and I've been
on his show by the way and he compared
my views to Hitler not a joke um but
even him I do find that he's calling out
both sides and trying to be a decent
arbiter for the most part so you can't
just dismiss everybody and I'm not I
would never sit here and tell you that
I'm the end-all be-all of everything by
any stretch I'm doing the best I can I'm
trying to have conversations with people
all over the map you guys see on
wednesday we have Lawrence Krauss on
who's an astrophysicist that's genius
really is against Trump because of
science because he thinks the Trump
simply doesn't have the mental capacity
to deal with huge scientific issues and
really lays into him and then you know
what the week after I'm gonna have
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton Hillary
Rosen on who's a big Clinton supporter
and then I'm gonna have some Trump
people and yeah we'll keep mixing it up
all right with that why is building a
great studio so important rather than
trying to spend that effort trying to
get access to more people trying to
navigate time schedules an organized to
date so why is building the studio so
important basically we need like it's
the final step like we need a limited
ability to shoot whenever we want
whatever week that's that's the only
thing that's that we have now that's
separating us right I can do this i'm
sitting at a computer on a box you
should see my spring setup here looks
ridiculous like we need to have that
studio so that i can do either my goal
would be look if we can get the numbers
to line up right at you two breaths
coming in properly and all that i would
love to be doing introduced every day or
be doing some more new stuff or some
combination thereof or we could shoot
all kinds of other things like what we
need basically is the unfettered access
we have unfettered access to you right
now even though youtube's telling you
there's a plugin a lot of you read on
subscribe and apparently some of this
stuff's not going to be the audio wasn't
working but what we need is that it's
just the final key to freedom so if you
if you believe in the things that i'm
talking about you think that that this
show is health conversation which that
you know I get that more than anything
else it's people saying you know I've
shown your show to somebody that I
disagree with I get emails from
Christian conservative saying you know I
can't stand all these liberals but I
like what you do it I get emails from
liberal people saying you know I help
this show has helped me breach the gap
with conservatives or whatever we just
need our own home to do it at so the
student of the rat which has been great
but we have to pay them every time we
use it so it eventually became for each
time you know the way YouTube grep works
it became it becomes eventually it's not
financially sound just keep doing more
and more and more because sometimes the
cost of the studio is actually more than
we can ever earn on the particular video
so this will allow us to get ahead and
really
fully owned it ourselves as I said I had
to take out a huge loan to do it but I'm
confident in this and we know we're
building properly and I hope you'll join
us for the ride so anyone that donates
over 50 on patreon will get a live shout
out right now we're over a hundred on
paypal and what we got this comment is
from patreon who were giving top already
generated asking patreon please get
James will keep on ASAP you must have
seen this video today tons of people are
asking so the comment was about James
O'Keefe in this video I saw a few
minutes of it cuz obviously I've had a
bit bit of a busy day um but it sounds
like this is goes to one of those things
where it's so hard to know who to trust
these things right you guys know I do
not trust the mainstream media and I
wish they'd be you know give a little i
don't want false equivalence but i want
a little more balance when it comes to
if you're gonna talk about Trump and
[ __ ] all day long you got also address
WikiLeaks doesn't have to be 5050 that
wouldn't make sense either just putting
an artificial we have to do a half man
and half you know whatever but but
there's such a lack of trust in
everything so I did watch some of the
video yeah I guess at some level you
have to question some of his political
motives but it does sound like the
Democrats have intentionally inflamed
violence at Trump things to make it seem
like the Trump supporters and more
violent than they are what I can tell
you is that from the one time that I was
at anything that you could be resembled
at trump rally which was when I spoke at
UCLA with my life there were hundreds
and hundreds of kids there and there
were about I don't know five or six
hundred trying to get into the event and
then there were another maybe hundred
outside protesting it the protesters
were the ones that were violent they
were throwing garbage cans and spitting
on people and they created a human chain
so no one could get in so they're not
against walls if they're creating it
themselves um and they were found
pounding on the door there to try to get
in while we were talking they called in
a bomb threat me they were doing
extremely illegal things I mean my
limits I whether you agree or disagree
with Milo it's like here's a bleach
blonde british gay guy let the guy speak
and then you know what a minute later uh
you know retort in his speech with your
own and do a counter protest outside but
you can't stop people from speaking and
this is why i've been so disappointed
with the left and that's why when we
talk about the trigger warnings and safe
spaces and all of these things
creating a generation of people that are
so afraid of hearing other ideas that
eventually you never want to hear
another idea because you're so morally
right that is the scariest thing there
is we need to have these conversations
so it's a big mess so I will watch the
full okie thing and I'll comment I'll
commented on it tomorrow and what I've
seen the whole thing all right just
let's do a quick radio reset you guys
most you try dogs on Sirius XM for a
couple years so radio reset just letting
you know what we're doing so we are
raising funds we're trying to hit 30,000
on patreon we did not think this was
going to happen so quickly where we be
able to build our own studio but a few
things fell into place and we found a
place that is just perfect for what we
need and you guys have given us the
budget to do the show we the way we want
as I said in the video this morning if
CNN came to me right now and said we'll
give you a million dollars to do this
show I would not do it we're doing
something that's so cool this connection
is real and it's at expressing there's
something so awesome happening here I'm
so proud of it so you can go to
patreon.com/scishow band reporter Rupert
record calm / donate if you do 50 on
patreon I'll give you a live i'll skype
with you after to thank you and if you
do 100 on paypal skype at the effort
thank you and we're doing this all week
by the way so we're doing this today on
facebook and youtube tomorrow we're
going to do a happy hour so i'm going to
do some shots of patron for patreon i
think last time we did it was I did a
shot every 250 bucks I they're doing
like seven shots in an hour so I was not
was a rough night but I do it do it and
yeah so there's a lot of cool climate
Chinese 30k and we're trying to get to
30 k so we can build this studio you
know it's not cheap obviously to build a
studio but this will fully 100% be ours
we will an unfiltered unfettered access
to the studio we can do longer
interviews we can do more interviews we
can do we could do new segments we're
gonna have a green screen area I mean
we're really this this really really
really is the is the final step to do
anymore and by the way you know Damon
and mirror we're a small team here and I
should thank all of you that constantly
email me offering to work for free
without a zillion people offering to
work for free event keep all people
offer to move across the
entry to come work for us so my hope
though is that soon we'll be able to
start hiring some people at 30 I think
we're going to get there we'll hire an
editor that people doing graphics for us
that we pay as contractors but I really
want to we could really expand this
thing now so it's very cool alright cool
so I'm going to give a couple couple
shoutouts want to thank Brad on patreon
and drew I'm sorry Andrea on patreon
neyo on patreon me up let's start that
over got a little head of myself Brad on
patreon Andrea on patreon Neil on paypal
Luke on patreon Jonathan on patreon and
gianluca on patreon thank you to you
guys you're giving us the budget to
build the show out properly and as I
said the cool thing is that you know
some people don't have a little extra
income and if you do by supporting us
you're you're actually keeping this show
free for other people and that's what
it's about it's about spreading ideas so
that's very cool question atria us from
viral Liberty I really don't like Trump
but I feel like Hillary will start World
War three do you think an ally with
Russia Trump is elected I really don't
like Trump but I think Hillary will
start World War three can be a lie with
Russia if Trump is elected so this
Russia thing look I did a video last
week what's the situation with Russia
because it's very obvious that over the
next couple weeks we're going to
propaganda flying every which direction
about Russia look is Russia working with
WikiLeaks to affect our election I don't
know that for a fact but it seems like
there could be some collusion now at the
same time pratts are not claiming that
the emails that are being leaked are not
legit so there's two separate issues
you're one issue related to WikiLeaks is
the damning stuff that's in the emails
it does seem like the Clinton campaign
has coordinated with the new york times
with political with CNN and a few other
places you guys see that there's some
pay to play if you give the foundation
of certain amount of money you might get
an ambassadorship or some other types of
things so there does seem to be some of
that then at the same time is it
possible that WikiLeaks either is in
cahoots with the Russian government or
is somehow secretly working with Trump
campaign or something because obviously
they are very odd Hillary now they're
they're against state power as general
rule
Clinton happens to be the one candidate
out of these two who's uh Emma wants a
little a little camera time I guess um
Clinton happens to be the one that's
been in the government all these years
so they were [ __ ] on her then they than
they do on Trump so that that that just
works to her disadvantage in this case
also she did some really sloppy stuck
with her emails and classified stuff
which we know about and you know
destroying emails and iPads and
bleaching things and the whole thing so
my feeling at the moment is that it does
seem that the Democrats have more of a
reason to be hawkish on Russia because
the because Russia or WikiLeaks or
whatever whatever you want to say has
more [ __ ] on them so oddly could it be a
war with Russia I don't think Russia
really wants to be a war with us but
there does seem to be some sort of new
cold brew it cold war brewing but it
seems to be coming from the Democrats
and let you know what I said earlier is
that if WikiLeaks really has some
serious stuff on Hillary that's going to
keep getting leaked the real risk is
that what if they announced some major
bombshell the day before the election or
even worse the day after the election so
what if she gets elected and then they
announce some mass you know really huge
scandal or they're able to blackmail her
look you guys know my feelings about
conspiracy theories as Carl Sagan said
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence so I don't like
going down that route but we have that's
the problem we don't have a media that
seems like we can trust it if you have a
brain and you're a logical thinker you
gotta just you have to try to find some
truth in it for yourself I think um and
hopefully the truth that you find mr. is
the real truth out there um all right so
what do we got are you building for a
network where you enable others who
speak honestly to express interviews on
shows are you in heading towards a
network where you can connect with other
people and help other people expand
their views and all that kinds up we're
thinking about it we're thinking about
it I mean now we didn't know how quick
this was going to happen it's incredible
I mean we just left aura in June and did
the independent thing I I did not think
that five months later we'd be in a
position to do the home studio but once
we do this that's the other thing we're
going to build this thing out so that
hope
I'll be able to bring in other youtubers
we can either there I can let them use
the studio we can figure out other ways
of doing network thing maybe we'll
become an MCN which is multi-channel now
youtube I mean wait we might be able to
distribute license the show to some
networks I mean there's so much stuff
that we can do here and and by the way
there's no the reason that this is
working that's the reason that this is
working is that there's not a home for
this there really isn't home birth I
mean think about if I was trying to do
this and I was on CNN would that make
any sense would it make any sense if I
was on Fox News or on MSNBC I don't
think any of those things would make any
sense so we can figure there there is a
political movement brewing you know
everyone's everyone's talking about they
talk about the burning movement which
Hillary basically killed and the BNC
killed they talk about the Trump
movement but there's another movement
brewing here people that are disaffected
on both sides that really do want
answers there that are liberals that can
look at a conservative and say you know
I disagree with you may be on on tax
policy or I disagree with you on
abortion but I know you're not really
the enemy and a conservative that look
at a liberal and say you know I know you
want maybe more in terms of social
safety net or something like that or
maybe you're meant legalizing marijuana
and I'm not but I know you're not yet
and I do think there's a new center
developing this is going to take time
but you know what on the show it was
obviously a supporting Trump now and
really laid out some of the tactics of
trunk of why it's working he said that
out of this ki asked some opportunity
lies and I think that's the opportunity
but it will only be there we grab it so
so there's something happening here if
we got a crab that's that's the key
Vitaly all right come a quick couple
quick shout outs uh Nathan on patreon
Thank You Louis on paypal thank you and
Kevin on patreon thank you guys
appreciate your giving us the budget to
go ahead and build this show the best
way we know how and and it's been
amazing it really is amazing you know I
wish if I just here I'm going to look at
my phone for one second show you that
I'm not making this up the amount of
emails that we get at the moment can you
see this right there I have 8,000 what
does that say 8930 five emails in my
inbox right now I just went up when I
five
um because because you guys are emailing
me constantly and twitter my twitter
used to be fun for me it's becoming like
it's so out of control that i can barely
look at my tensions anymore but this is
this is good because it means
something's happening means something's
happened and where a bully but we're
able to partner up with the right people
that we want to partner up with when we
can and and really control what we're
doing it all right are you worried by
the increased censorship on youtube so
would you never think about starting
your home site are you worried about the
increased censorship on youtube I would
you ever consider starting outside
accident this is big and I've tried not
to make a huge issue out of it because I
don't know exactly what's going on and
it's funny because so much these days
feels like a conspiracy theory and if
you want to go down that route there's
no end to it right so look here's the
issue with YouTube YouTube has told me I
have emails from one from this morning
they that there is a bug on our channel
and that's why people are being
unsubscribed we also know that our feet
isn't working properly so like our video
with Zoltan expand from last Friday for
the first six hours it had like 80 views
like it just didn't go out to the feed
um then confirm that this is hitting
certain channels they won't tell us what
other channels it's going to they don't
tell us how long it's going to take they
won't address any of it publicly so do I
think that there possibly going after my
political beliefs I guess anything's
possible but again I don't want to go
down to conspiracy route um but you know
there are other issues related to
youtube because we know that there d
monetizing things that they don't like
so for example all of our videos with
Douglas Murray Douglas Murray who's the
most brilliant east Hitchens to I this
guy's incredible they said no this is
not you can make money on that so that's
another reason why patreon is so
important youtube doesn't pay out a lot
per video it's like two dollars per
thousand views or something but by doing
patreon I don't have to worry we don't
have to do topics based on how much
we're going to make you know what I mean
and we don't have to do click bait I'm
very proud of the way we treated this
channel look at our look at our videos
look at the way we title tag and our
thumbnails I treat this the way that I
would want new use and information to be
treated so we know that there that we
can game the system and by the way we
used to do it years ago when we first
started to just try to get more clicks
and all that we don't do it anymore I
think that can work against
numbers but I think it works for us in
terms of feeling that I'm doing the
right thing so anyway so I don't know I
don't want to put it out of conspiracy
they're dealing with giant servers and I
know these things these problems are
affecting other channels I know my
friend Dave Colin who's doing his
channel I know he's been hit too so I
don't know that it's politically
motivated not only we want to think
about that my love being on YouTube and
I love the community but that is the key
that's why patreon is so great even if
it was even if I was being totally
manipulated and the algorithm was set up
to hurt us if we're okay on patreon it
really doesn't matter yeah this is
Malcolm on patreon Dave why do you think
it is that third-party candidates always
go for the presidency round and build a
party that gets elected into Congress
[ __ ] god that's a great question so
Malcolm said why don't third parties why
do they always go for the presidency and
don't become a smaller party person Go
Local and so I've said this many times
this has been one of the things that's
been so disappointing about the
Libertarian Party the ideas that they
had the ideas of social liberalism you
because you're for small government you
don't you wouldn't care if someone
smokes weed certainly not if someone
smokes medicinal marijuana they're sick
and they can do something to help
themselves I don't know how anyone can
be against that can you imagine what
right do you have any of you are against
Iran saying no please let me know but
forget what your what your political
position is if someone was sick with
something you can sir your Parkinson's
you Alzheimer's you have a whatever it
is and you can smoke something or ingest
something or take it a cookie form or
whatever it is to make yourself feel
better what quite what another person or
the government have to tell you not to
do that that's crazy so a
libertarian-leaning a libertarian and
you may not care about gay people per se
but you would say wait a minute wait
what does that have to do with the state
two men want to enter a contract and if
two women one enter a contract or a man
and a woman or whatever it else then
that has nothing to do with the state so
a lot of the things that I believe in
from a liberal perspective can also be
rationalized from a libertarian
perspective which i think is really
great because then it shows that that
liberals and libertarians shouldn't be
against each other even if you don't
agree with why you come to the same
conclusion if you come to the same
conclusion that's actually pretty cool
so my
one of my disappointments with the
Libertarian Party is that you're
completely right now them they have to
be a party why aren't people running on
these ideas of social liberalism and
fiscal conservatism right we don't care
what you do in your private life I don't
care what you do in your private life I
hope you don't care what I do my private
life and then at the same time before
lower taxes not for adventurous Wars but
have a strong defense so that we don't
have to use it and and let the free
market do as much as it can I mean
personally I'm not a full libertarian
that I want no social safety net cuz I
think you have to have one I think have
to have some social services in yeah and
i'm not against helping people at
elephant rather like but all of those
are just the little details but the
libertarian ideas should have more
traction right now and that's why i
wanted Gary Johnson at least in the
debate again I said this now a thousand
times Gary Johnson was not a great
libertarian certainly not a great
candidate I like him personally I had
him on the show and I chatted with him
and he's a nice guy could be sitting
right here I put my arm around and smoke
a joint but he wasn't a great example he
wasn't a great standard bearer for
libertarianism when it was so that's my
disappointment with this election forget
Trump and forget Hillary is that this
was a chance for a new idea to be born
because solely people are so frustrated
with both of them that it's like oh
there could have been a chance not the
gary johnson was gonna be present but
but a same libertarian that had a
command of the issues and a clear
strategy and all that and spoke well
cleanly I think could have done a lot of
good so it so that means is
disappointing but I would love to see
the libertarians and by the way not just
the Libertarians the Green Party all
these other parties so there is nothing
in our Constitution that says we have to
be a two-party system there there are
strengths to having two parties but
there are a lot of weaknesses too there
are plenty of other strong democracies
that have a lot of other parties and
look that comes with its own set of
problems too because then you have to
build a coalition and then you could
have a party that has three seats and
coalition field a lot of power because
they can topple the government a lot of
different things but we need to
understand and this is why we need to do
more about international politics and
why I'll continue to bring on people
from all over the world because we need
to understand that this this system our
system still pretty good
America is still pretty good for all our
problems but it could be better but it's
only can be better by by us pushing more
ideas out there and letting other things
be heard um alright cool so reminder we
are raising funds we're trying to get to
30,000 on pegatron we're building out
our home studio we're doubling the
amount of shows to per week for start
live streaming more I won't have to do
this from my ikea couch would actually
be in the studio once this thing's built
out we gotta put lighting in and we got
an air-conditioned and soundproof and do
all kind Rai wall and all kinds of stuff
and we're very excited so it's
patreon.com/scishow been reported Ruben
report com such donate if you do 50 on
patreon i'll skype with you to thank you
after this and if you do 100 on paypal
skype to thank you after this we're
doing live shoutouts for anybody that
donates while i'm talking right now
actually the only three seats left oh
you talking what I get it patently once
he left to 250 so I want so there's a
couple really cool things that we're
doing our patron so the beauty of
patreon is that whatever you give
different levels that you give at you
get different things so if you give $35
you get your t-shirt 50 hours you get a
mug and your funding the show right now
we have one we have three slots left at
one hundred dollars and at a hundred
dollars I do two of these we do to group
hangouts with 10 people we've got people
from all over the world that I've been
doing them with four months and
sometimes people do it for a few months
and then drop out that's great so we've
got three slots left if you want to
become part of our monthly google
hangout we only do 20 20 people can do
it we've got three slots left on that
and only one saw left on the 250 per
month which is a that's just a
one-on-one hang out with me so if you
want to just hang out with me just the
two of us we've only got one shot left I
wish I could do more all that stuff I
can't you know spend every day talking
all day long but it's been amazing
connecting with you guys I'm talking to
people in India and I'm talking to
people and hungry and in Sweden and and
I even in the United States and Canada
whatever else and it's just it's so cool
and tumbling and it's awesome what you
guys are doing and then you're
connecting with each other by the way
one of the things on patreon I think
it's the ten dollar reward you can
download the patreon app here it's a
free app on on
itunes store and you can download the
app and there's a chat in here so it's
sort of like whatsapp and I just jump in
there whenever I'm doing my thing I was
in an uber the other day I jumped in
there and a whole bunch of people jumped
in and we will talk about stuff it's
very cool so you can do that I was a
question from patrons from Alex for such
an evidence-based guy any idea why sam
Harris seems so unconcerned by Hillary's
apollon tracker clearly not neither are
good candidates with some clinton's were
seem to be deaf dumb and blender actual
disasters history and obsessed by
Trump's clumsy letter ok so that was
alex on patreon in that and the gist of
the question was for such a reasonable
guy why doesn't Sam see more bets Sam
heresy more bad Hilary look I can't
speak for Sam you guys know I hold him
in the highest regard I could hold any
any person um first up we don't have to
see eye to eye on everything I think I
do see more wrong with live Hilary then
then he does i agree with a lot of his
critique of Trump by the way but i can i
can disagree with him or not see things
exactly the same as him and guess what
that doesn't mean he's gross and racist
or doesn't mean he's evil or what's the
newt the Middle East um I think I think
that a lot of people are begrudging Lee
supporting Hillary because they really
don't like Trump and I think there's a
certain amount of people that are
originally supporting Trump because they
don't like Hillary and that's just kind
of where we're at um you know I think
there's a fear amongst a certain amount
of people that from that what does
America look like the next day did we
just burn down the system like is this
now our all rules off for as whacked out
as that system is and the media is then
everything else like there's it does
seem like a massive risk now the people
that are supporting Trump would say well
it's going to be better so go for it um
i don't know i don't know but i have no
problem and i and i assure you that Sam
wouldn't have a problem with us not
seeing totally eye to eye on that by the
way I address this in the in the
facebook video we just did but i'll
mention it here and i'd love to hear
your thoughts so you know I said the
thing about Gary Johnson and I wanted to
get into fifteen percent to get some new
ideas in the debate we failed but I
think I did something or I know that I
did something that I believe in it I
think it was a principle thing to do I'm
in California so who I vote for
ultimately what
or so maybe so for me a protest vote of
Gary Johnson just so the number is a
little higher could make some sense my
feeling though for for the purposes of
the show is that I'm going to continue
bringing on people on both sides I
Hilary Rosen on who's a big Clinton
person coming on in a couple weeks this
week we have Lawrence Krauss on who's an
astrophysicist who really doesn't like
Trump you guys know we've had some Trump
people out of all that work more Trump
pea pod and all over the mat my feeling
is that I don't think I'm gonna say who
I ultimately vote for because I hope
that this show Rose enough in the next
year that i will get President Clinton
or president Trump or whoever it is and
to fit in terms of objectivity for me to
say I'm supporting this person seems
doesn't seem like the best idea that
said I will continue to hold their feet
to the fire no matter what whoever gets
in and I will continue to bring on
people that are both critical of an
administration and supportive
administration all that but I'm curious
what your thoughts are on that because
I've been thinking about a lot it's one
of the questions that people ask me the
most like at the end of the day what do
I gain so I'm going to keep doing
interviews the way I do I try to be as
honest and do everything with as much
integrity as I have um but ultimately
what do I gain so I that's right before
the team of the day before the election
I said well I'm potent this way well now
I get X amount of people angry at me and
then when I interview that person
because I do plan on making it happen
we're building this [ __ ] um then
it's gonna see my commander in the tank
for somebody or I was in tech for the
other person and I'm treating this
person unfairly so I i I'd love to hear
what you think on that maybe you guys
can convince me to change how do you
plan original larger audience could this
show potentially game commercial
momentum on Main Street platform at e3
year so how do you want to get how can
you get a bigger audience can we get
more commercial success and all that so
we've been talking to a couple networks
about distribution one of the things
that is really cool about the home
studio ideas because we're on production
company and we'll have our own
production facility is that I could do a
show that embody way we can do this show
for what it costs us to do one show
basically we can do our show for the
year for what it costs some cable news
shows to do probably an episode up when
you factor in you know the salaries that
the talents making and the host
making and when you factor in the amount
of people that they hired a move cameras
and all this stuff so we can do this
show up at a really slim trade of budget
which is which is really cool and I
assure you that David mirror myself are
not rolling the dough because of this
but we're building something that's
really nice so yeah we've been talking
to his couple networks about
distribution meaning that we would do
the show as we want I don't want anyone
to have any other control of the show
and I would not sign a deal that would
not be transparent about that but we
would do the show make the package and
then let them distribute it so we've
been talking to a couple networks about
that I had a big call with with an
agency this week that he wants to need
to do some other stuff for television so
we're figuring out all of those pieces
like there's a lot here can we grow out
a network out of it you know either as i
said earlier do an MCN a multi-channel
network on youtube or can we get this
television in a different way there's a
lot of ways but i think what i really
really believe that we're just at the
beginning and the interesting thing is
that the cool part really is that we've
built this through work through hard
work and a real the same really build an
audience you know i mean we didn't do
this because we had a big budget we
didn't do this because we bought views
or because we had ton of money to spend
on social media as we did have any of
that we've done this I work I keep too
much that's that's how we did it
question is from dr. Christian on
patreon would you consider doing a show
on how impressive left and kind of all
right tendencies are taking all your
other what is happening in the u.s. in
terms of free speech depression is now
being damaged on campuses media so the
question basically was when you do more
on Europe related to the regressive left
and the all right i think he was from
its dr. christian from germany and that
some of these ideas are taking root in
college campuses there i mean i heard
this from people all over the world it's
probably you know this is what i get
emailed it out more than anything else
about just that this ideology on both
sides by the way because you know for
the for the albright people and please
challenge me on this right now because i
know there's a lot of you in there in
the comment section for all the people
that think that Trump will be the pure
answer to the free speech problem look
this is a guy who does threaten to sue
reporters what do you think well
happen when when someone does some when
a really good reporter does some
investigative research on his
administration do you think he will be
all about free speech and now I get
politically I don't know that there's
anyone on earth that wants this this
awful regressive social justice nonsense
crushed more than me I've spent so much
blood sweat and tears upon this stuff
and talking about this stuff but I don't
know that Trump is the answer to that so
that's the he might be the short term
answering that he would destroy it at
the height of its popularity but in
terms of the long-term health of free
speech does President Donald Trump seem
like the guy that's going to give us the
best free press I don't know but by the
way I will also say the same time that
you know everyone I think people are
really start a freak like that the whole
country could spin out of control right
now let's not forget our system is
really strong and our forefathers and
our founding fathers we're really smart
by creating a checks and balances system
and then 33 wings of government three
branches of government so that the
executive branch the presidential range
is just supposed to sign laws into their
supposed to sign bills into law the
legislative branch Congress intended
supposed to write them in the judicial
branch is supposed to make sure that
those well it's been vehicle that's how
it's all supposed to work now he's
changing because the executive branch
every president for the past 40 years
has taken more and more power from the
executive branch and then when you
couple that we've had a pretty shitty
Congress and Senate that has a lab of
them to do it because they don't do
anything themselves and then in
factoring that the next president might
be able to put in as many days for
Supreme Court justices you could have a
real powered shift dynamic so now I'm
some sort of saying citing backwards
because I was saying that our system is
strong it can withstand even one of that
which I do think it can but in this case
we're also dealing with situation where
a lot of the Supreme Court can be
flipped so there's good arguments on
each side and what I consistently try to
do I dinner last night with two people
and I'm not going to mention who they
are but two public people who are
well-known public people basically and
one of them is a big Trump person or one
of them too big Hillary person and we
like we fully had and out like we were
arguing about the whole thing discussing
the whole thing and we all SAT there and
had dinner together had a glass of a
couple basswood and and left on good
terms and we and we have to remember
all november nights gonna roll around
it's going to be the day after the
election whatever happened we're all
still going to be Americans for those of
us that are American I hope
international audience too and we have
to realize that we have to we have to
get along so we have to you know it's
one thing look if Trump and Clinton are
just going to demonize the [ __ ] out of
each other till for the next three weeks
which it looks like they are I think
that most of us want to be better than I
think we can we can do it but we gotta
do you got it all right let me do a
couple shoutouts I want to thank Chad on
patreon I want to thank jonathan on
patreon andrew on patreon and kirk on
patreon and kyle on patreon up his
pledge so thank you guys remember if you
donate 50 on patreon right now i'll
skype with you to thank you personally
after this and if you don't need 100 on
paypal off thank you on the skype and
we're trying to hit our 30,000 go we are
building a home studio or doubling
content starting next week you guys did
this you guys absolutely built this
thing I mean we I had no idea when we
launched our patreon campaign and we
left you know I left the job left a good
cushy gig e or they treated me well I
David mirror left we all quit our jobs
we left our health insurance all that
stuff to try this and its work and the
show the show is just grown and grown
and grown since and you guys you guys
push me to do better work and I hope I
haven't let you down and I don't intend
that this is from Joseph I'm picture I'm
you talk a lot about media bias and your
post do you think the liberal media is
more focus on supporting Clinton or
stopping Trump I talk a lot about media
bias do I think that the media is more
focused on stopping Trump or supporting
Clinton a liberal you know the liberal
media so uh basically speaking the
what's considered the mainstream media
leans left so inherently they're gonna
like Clinton more than they like Trump
now it's funny I see reporters sometimes
say well I don't you know I don't
support anybody or my feelings don't
come through in my right acre reporters
don't have emotions or something like
that such nonsense it said old [ __ ] and
we have to be very aware of that that
everyone has their own biases in
whatever you know like you guys can ask
me anything here and i will answer it as
honestly as I as I possibly can but to
say that I don't have I
is I try to be as honest as I can but
everyone has their own their own biases
their own way of looking at the world
all that stuff so the mainstream media
basically leans left so they were I
think most of the media actually really
like Bernie more than anything else I
think there was a real feel of
revolution and its movement and at that
time they were given Hillary a lot of
[ __ ] like she there was a lot of that
wall street and you know her bad
decisions in Iraq and let me up and
things like that then because Trump came
in and the media really hates Trump and
Trump really hates the media and he's
the true outsider in this situation
they've changed their fire now they see
one that will keep them sort of safe in
their position and trunk as the outsider
so I do think it's a case now where they
ate Trump more than they like Clinton
but again this is this is a gem doing a
gross generalization here because
there's all kinds of people in the media
and there are media a family left in the
lean right and that are more centrist
and there are good reporters I David
Sirota on in a couple I think next week
who I think is an extremely good
reporter who calls out both sides and I
think he's a bit of a defect he like me
um Amy get some truth out of him I wish
it was easier it will be nice if it was
easier ought to cover some issues and
gas which are unique to other countries
not necessarily related to us yes
absolutely i'm glad you asked that a do
i plan on covering some things that are
not necessarily unique to the United
States you know I've tried I think
relevant to what you see on cable news
here I've run a lot of people from
different countries to talk about
different things and I had the head of
the assyrian army on and i've had t know
Simon dodgy from Sweden on and you know
obviously I had Douglas mari in the UK
and a whole bunch of a whole bunch of
different people and I had a bye on
Samuel Rahman from from Kurdish regional
government all kinds of things we don't
do a good job of that the United States
everyone's always talking about us so we
stopped talking about everybody else and
I think it's one of our problems we've
become very myopic that our world that
leaving rule the universe and that's not
how it should be so absolutely would you
know we have to sort of do the election
thing to a certain degree
no but I look forward actually to
expanding what we're doing beyond that
and that will also be a nice part of
having the studio will be able to do a
lot more I mean just physically we can
do a lot we hit that will hire an editor
and we'll be able to just turn out that
much more content and the more content
we tried out the more money little urn
on YouTube which eventually hopefully
allows us to hire a lot more people like
it starts becoming a nice little engine
you guys were given us the cold to going
to start it this is a flea / philippe on
patreon I davison introduced change the
way you used to think about an issue but
no racism in America of gun control
plant that's a good one so Philippe said
did any my interviewers change my
opinion opinions on things well first
off I can definitely say that I've
learned from virtually every interview
that I've done I really do try to go
into these things with an open mind you
know sometimes for certain interviews I
feel like I have to be extremely
well-read on you know I've had to read
all their books or I've had to really
pay attention to every little thing they
said and some people I try to go in with
a little less because then I feel like I
could ask the question that the average
person might ask too so I can learn as
much to write um let's see I think there
were a couple people that I think I
learned particularly from I'd say the
interview with Larry elder which isn't
one of my best moments actually but we
never edit for content by the way you
know we don't edit the only time we edit
is will be for like a camera shot if we
want to get a different reaction shot
but I always tell my guys don't edit for
content meaning if someone says if
something makes me look stupid or says
something that that isn't right don't
edit that out I don't mind being shown
up or being flawed I am flawed but Larry
elder we had him on and I think he
didn't know that much about me at the
time and I think he came in very
combative thinking that I was a liberal
and he's a libertarian and that you know
no he's not he's a libertarian but he's
more of a conservative I supposed and I
think he thought that the interview is
going to be very combative and I talked
a bit about systemic racism he really
turned it on me but to prove systemic
racism not to prove the racism this was
nobody I don't think
denies that um but we talked about black
lives matter and I think he laid out
things that if now I do see as more true
that sort of fit within this sjw
oppression Olympics thing um and he
really called me out on it and I didn't
have good responses and yeah we could
have been ended it out but I don't mind
uh being shown up because that's how you
learn right like that that's exactly how
you learn let me do a couple couple
shoutouts want to thank Nick on patreon
dr. Christian who I mentioned earlier in
Germany he just upped his patreon Mike
on patreon digital stickman incorporated
just donated a hundred dollars on paypal
so I will skype with you after this and
Benjamin on patreon thank you guys if
this content had look you know everyone
pays for you pay for cable or you pay
for netflix or whatever else it is we
got a small team here but we're building
something as i said earlier a fraction
of the price of what the costs you know
for cable news try to imagine like a
show pick any of these shows that you
take Anderson Cooper on CNN eight
o'clock show they got like you know
probably ten cameraman massive overhead
in the studio all of the the people
behind the scenes and you know janitors
and all that stuff really I don't know
what it cost him to do one episode but i
would venture to say when you especially
when you factor in Anderson salary and
you know they get cars for all these
people are like cater and all this food
and all the other stuff i would venture
to say that a year of what we do a year
truly of what we do cost less than one
episode of these some of these cable
news shows that that's more higher in
what some of them are not are at that
fancy um but it's very it's very cool
what's going on here you guys you guys
are helping us do this and and i hope
that you know and i think that you do
see this as an investment in yourself
like if you want these ideas to get out
there you want the left to be liberal
again if you want to be able to sit you
know we all have people in our family
that we don't agree with politically and
hopefully you don't hate them for it and
you don't d friend them on Facebook and
throw throw food at them across the
table so that's how we should be with
our nation these are our citizens as i
said
November night we're still all going to
be Americans so we got to separate some
of that stuff and for the people that
are watching internationally it's funny
like people on one hand everyone's like
sick of hearing by the United States all
time and then the other and everyone
can't stop watching this freaking thing
so it's uh it's really something so okay
quick reset remember it is
patreon.com/scishow bin report and
Reuben portico / donate and let's say
we're here we're about to crack 23,000
so let's crack twenty-three thousand
dollars we're going to be doing this all
week by the way I'm going to be doing in
facebook live and YouTube live videos
all week long tomorrow we'll do a happy
hour with you guys so if you're around
this time if you want to if you want to
have a drink with me and we'll do some
shots of patron when we could certain
mark then Wednesday night of course is
the debate which the entire world is
going to be watching this thing I'm
guessing you probably around 200 million
people will be watching and then we'll
do some fun stuff on on thursday and
friday so we're doing a big push here to
build this thing out i'm meeting with
the contractor we're laying out the
blueprints on how we're going to build
this whole thing out there may be a
couple weeks when we're when we're
building this thing out that will be
doing a little more on skype because
skype if we don't have to do exactly
from the studio so while it's under
construction but we'll do all kinds of
behind-the-scenes things so you can see
the construction being done um yeah so
it's really cool what we're doing here
you guys are enabling us to do it it's
awesome and i truly thank you for it so
all right well knock out a couple of
questions and then and then i think
that's it for today well yeah what do
you see an undeclared him making these
illegal to look at them so i don't have
you guys saw this but Chris diploma on
CNN basically implied he might have
worded it a little strange and you guys
know I don't like to merge everyone's
intentions but he implied that if you
look at WikiLeaks or if you have the
WikiLeaks documents you could be doing
something illegal that they're allowed
to as a new news organization but you
can it seemed like whether there's some
degree of truth or that or not it seemed
like a very strangely chilling tactic to
imply don't tweet about this or don't
share it on Facebook or something
because the government come after you
were allowed to on CNN which means we'll
pick with
important for you to hear so again again
the main issue with this is that it
takes an issue that I understand a lack
of trust in media which is something
that a lot of the Trump people have and
in many cases very deserving least so
then if so imagine you're the average
Trump supporter you don't trust the
media right and then quit Chris Cuomo
whose brother is the Democratic mayor of
New York City but it's pretty decent guy
uh but then you see him saying no don't
look at the WikiLeaks basically we're
allowed to will tell you what to look at
that does feel it just feels off right
it just feels sign Ian and groups um so
it's shitty shitty shitty where you go
ah see I think it'd be cool if you're a
champion album your readers could submit
potential questions for your interviews
ah so that might be one of them will
work around yeah that's interesting so a
few guy few you asked this like and I
see a lot of other interviewers do this
type of thing where they'll say you know
I'm interviewing so and so what do you
want me to ask them so I've really tried
not to do that because I think it's my
job to come up with the right questions
to ask people um I think we could do
something we're on patreon you find on a
fifty-dollar Dawson yeah oh so we're
thinking what whoa so here's what we're
thinking that I think we may change some
things on patreon so that a fifty dollar
level what we would do is if you donate
the VI your questions for the guests get
put into a pool that I would answer just
for our patreon bonusing so in other
words for the people that are watching
the show uh normally on YouTube that's
still everything i'm still doing all
thinking don't worry about that but that
you would have an extra bonus if you
work hard at patreon to do that so
that's one of the things we're thinking
about really so I'll keep that in mind
um you know will do will do two more
questions and then we're going to do
this all week so for any of you that
jumped in it I appreciate it for those
of you that are that are on the fence
good go for it why not um all right what
a guy Oh see only two not pressuring
that's a lot of pressure
have you been invited to do any other
shows of podcasts and you like to listen
to you and Joe Rogan on shows is from
Michael on patients Michael on patreon
have I been on any other podcast things
yeah you could if you find just look
around on YouTube defiance of everything
so much he asked about Rogan
specifically so i was on rogue in about
a year ago and Joe has been great to me
because you know he is a huge huge
audience and I think the mark a truly
good person in this space is that he's
not afraid to share his audience you
know some people I know plenty of people
actually that are public people that
they don't want it you know I don't want
to promote other people because they
think it's gonna like chip away at their
audience Joe is a huge audience here eat
weeds me all the time he's been he's
been very good to me I would love to get
back on his show before the election so
I will reject him but if you just search
dave rubin joe rogan you'll find our
three hours together which was extremely
cathartic because it was at the
beginning of my adventure we had just
launched on or I was just starting to
talk about a lot of the regressive left
stuff and all that so zoo was really
enjoyed 30 it's a long time but I think
you'll enjoy that I'd love to have Joe
in you he's agreeing to do it the guy is
doing these for our interviews like
every day busy guy um all right let's
not get one more but remember what we're
doing here is we're fundraising to help
build our home studio google of
literally literally people say i say
literally on but i mean this literally
we will have no restrictions then we
will be able to tape whenever we want
3am yeah we can take just walk down the
hall we are creating a home studio we're
trying to hit 30,000 on patreon that
gives us the monthly budget to go ahead
and not only build this thing but get
the electric sound proofing the air
conditioning all of these things and
it's truly our our final step towards
full independence and then from there
how do we grow it well maybe we can
start growing a network I've got
obviously a whole bunch of youtubers
that I love that I think I can help
amplify their voices that that these are
voices that are not going to be heard on
mainstream I think there's just so much
that we can do by having own studio in
it and then maybe we'll distribute the
show through other networks I mean
there's a lot of things we can do and
this is it's funny but we're just at the
beginning again you know it's like it
never stops all right so this is your
last chance to
to donate and get a live shout out while
we're doing this right now it's 516
right now according to my clock here so
we'll go to 520 last chance for the live
shout outs I want to thank Eric who
jumped in at a hundred dollars on take
out so you'll be part of our google
hangouts and would be very cool you'll
see it's really really cool because
people all over the world connecting oh
I'm sorry that was on paypal not on
patreon but I thank you anyway and I
will thank you on skype privately um and
shall who just donated 50 on paypal and
nick who just donated on paypal and
Benjamin who just donated on paypal so I
thank you guys and you know your help
you're helping to build something you
know and for five bucks cost of one beer
and any picky though okay rose for
YouTube do you ever have insurance
features on your channel and be seen
only have never seen ask about return
speakers so I've had a couple people so
I've had dad sat on twice sam Harris was
on twice feisal saeed akhtar was on
twice he's actually in town next week so
maybe i can work out something with him
a couple people you know what's good is
it can grow this show out in a weird way
I guess it's not a weird way maybe it's
an obvious way but I do think that I've
come a better interviewer but i know
that i'll still become a better
interview because a lot of times when
you're first sitting down with somebody
you want to kind of get to know them you
have to ask about a lot of history
things and about them personally where
my hope is that as we grow this thing
out and especially as the show gets
bigger and more people know about me and
more people know about the guest but i
have on we have higher profile people
and all that and then fluffy stuff which
i try not to focus on obviously doing
these interviews that we be able to go
right into the meat as everything um so
I do like the idea of having repeat
people that and by the way when you have
repeat people you can see how people
have evolved on things I've certainly
evolved done things in and everyone
that's what a thinking flexible brain
should do alright cool so we are gonna
wrap in two minutes so if you want a
live shout out you got two minutes to do
it Ruben report cop such donate door
patreon.com/scishow bit apart whoo
today a lot of talking um yeah you guys
have helped build build something really
cool here I'm really throwing that is
also pre-chewed what role do you think
the show will take on an election
season's over in politics six packs each
other issues so that's a great question
what do I think will happen with the
show when the elections over in politics
takes a backseat to other issues look I
think that whatever happens whatever
happens a huge amount of people are
engaged right now so very shitty as it
may feel like tenor feel shitty
everyone's angry at everybody you don't
want to talk politics on your friends
because everyone's fighting I think a
lot of people after this are going to
want the system to be better and I think
that the key the key will be and what
I'm going to try to do is to keep people
engaged keep people that are frustrated
whether whether your candidate is is the
president or whether your candidate gets
crushed or or whatever it is or whether
you didn't vote hopefully you'll hope
even if you're voting for for whoever
hopefully you vote more than anything
else there are so many people that are
engaged right now and I think actually
the key to this is that for young people
you'll see the direct message that I
that I did which is coming out on
wednesday for my lawrence krauss entropy
where i talk about the system a little
bit well one of the things that that i
said is that imagine if you were a
millennial right now if you're a young
course you know it's easy to joke about
Millennials and I obviously do it
related to save space trigger warnings
all that stuff but if you are a
millennial right now this is your first
election this is the first taste of what
you feel like the sense of politics is
of a tenor of all this stuff up it would
feel pretty shitty I would I actually
have a lot of sympathy for for
Millennials in that regard so if you're
a millennial or you're 75 years old and
you're frustrated by the system well
then this is your chance to stay engaged
maybe if we had all been more engaged
and we all would have voted more and we
all would have demanded that our
politicians be better and all of that
stuff maybe get all done all that we
wouldn't ended up with this situation so
that's that's what I plan on doing but
when the elections over yeah then I can
shift back and we can do a little more
on science although I'm trying to we'll
see what we get a lot on science this
week but I'd love to do more more future
stuff I'd love to talk about
international politics war and foreign
policy board I mean we really will go
broad broad n forgetting the election I
mean the fact is we're going to double
the show's immediately to per show to
two per week I want to be able to do a
lot more so even if if it becomes that
nobody wins this election because the
rumor that epidemic mullen could leave
you to go which would stop either one of
them from getting to 270 and it gets
kicked class to the to the Congress and
we have to do a month of that I'll still
have room to talk about spiders all
right so I think we're gonna wrap it I
got just a couple more to give a shout
out to all right so we're just getting
our last update here so I want to thank
Daniel on paypal I want to thank no good
on page one who just upped from patreon
he's one of our guys in our in our
patreon chat that I enjoy talking to
who's held my my feet to the fire on a
couple issues and I also want to thank
Aaron on patreon just up from five to
ten alright so thank you guys reduce all
week we'll do the happy hour tomorrow
night with with some fresh bottle of
patron and probably some beer and then
beagle a debate night on wednesday and
then we'll go from there a bit more
shadow two more two more real quick mr.
fur on paypal and Michael on paypal
thank you guys you know I really I
really truly not only do I thank you but
I hope you believe that this is an
investment in the things that you care
about because you know so many people
say that they're afraid to sometimes I
get people saying they're afraid to
share our videos or they're afraid to
talk about this or that or the other
thing so if you need somebody to be out
there fighting for some of these things
i hope i've become one of those voices
and i hope there are many more this
thing succeeds if a thousand other
people come out that grow a thousand
other YouTube channels bigger than mine
well I certainly hope that that will
mean that we did something good you know
I mean it really will like it five years
from now there's people that are that
are way more popular than me doing this
and they put me out of business well
then maybe it'll be because I spark some
ideas in them so that's what you guys
are helping doing I appreciate it I
thank you and I've been talking for 18
hours consecutively so it's it's Roberta
work on such donate patreon com
such Reuben report and thank you and
yeah we'll do it again tomorrow alright
thanks everybody